والان الى تيك توك فلم تمنع التهديدات
والمحاولات الامريكيه لحظر تيك توك من
تحقيق التطبيق الصيني مكاسب اعلانيه واين
داخل الولايات المتحده نفسها
كشفت في تقرير لها عن ان تيك توك حقق
ارباحا كبيره من خلال اعلانات لصالح شركات
امريكيه كبرى مضيفه ان الاعلان على تطبيق
تيك توك الصيني في الولايات المتحده انما
بنسبه
11% خلال شهر مارس وحده وهو ارتفاع قياسي
في ظل ازمه حاليه ابرز الشركات المعلنه
على تيك توك كانت بيبسي امازون وابل وفقا
لبيانات من مجموعه تحليل التطبيقات سنسر
تاور زياده الاعلانات لم يكن المكتبه
الوحيده تيك توك بل ووفقا للتحليلات فان
الاصرار والرغبه على الاعلام من خلال
التطبيق ارتفع لدى المعلنين داخل المؤسسات
والشركات الكبرى في امريكا ومع ذلك دفعت
الضجه السياسيه ضد تيك توك بعض العلامات
التجاريه الى وضع خطط طوارئ مثل نقل
الانفاق الاعلاني الى منصات منافسه مثل
متى وجوجل استعدادا لحظر امريكيين محتمل
[موسيقى]